is is it just me is this just something
that i see where women don't take as
much accountability as men do
or have you seen that in real life like
do you agree do you disagree
um you can start okay i kind of
partially agree but at the same time
there was uh something that the last guy
said that just triggered something in me
like that's just not true like i think
women do take accountability and they
are shaped
from young as well
the levels of accountability are very
different and i definitely agree
um the fantasy spin
i think is very feminine and they're
kind of like i'm gonna uh i'm to reshape
reality i think that is a feminine trait
but that doesn't mean
that both sexes don't have an issue with
accountability i absolutely think that
there is an issue with accountability in
society for all sexes at this moment
where do you see that men don't take
accountability
i think men don't take accountability
for the
the status and um
actual kind of weight that they have put
on themselves and they complain about it
like it's women that have kind of put
this weight on their shoulders and how
they should shape their reality is like
because of women and and women don't
have that same pressure can i think
they've done that to themselves can i
have a specific example i'm just i don't
understand what you're talking about
even just being like okay so i
the role of being the breadwinner or the
one that has to provide everything i
think that is men that have put that on
themselves i don't think that has
anything to do with women you don't
think you don't think that has anything
to do with women when women want a guy
that makes um at least 30
more than them
no i i don't think there are that many
women that think that like that no no
it's if you survey women and ask them
they want a man that makes at least 30
percent more than that
and if a woman one of the number one
indicators of divorce is if a woman out
earns the man this is the difference
would that not come from men 100 what
would they not be the ones that are not
comfortable no no because because the
women initiate divorce so women leave is
70 to 80 no no 70 to 80 of the time
women leave and 90 if they're college
educated so the higher up a woman goes
in terms of income and status the more
likely she leaves okay now you're saying
she's leaving because she's earning more
and no i'm saying that she may be like
i'm not satisfied in this relationship
because
he has an issue with me earning more and
i don't want to stay in this dynamic so
from from what i've seen in the eyes you
can maybe correct like you can tell me
what you've seen because you guys you
know you i i see the girls
i i found when girls move up in in
making money they're around more men
that make more money than them so i
think
on some level they kind of wish they
were with the men they were working with
rather than their husbands
so they kind of see what they're not
getting and then they they leave
i can see that in some circumstances but
i actually think the troubles in a house
when a woman is earning more
isn't necessarily about that dynamic
condition
this goes back to women's women's nature
so yeah we've all heard the term
hypergamy so women are married for
across up social hierarchies so
naturally women are programmed to always
get the best that they can get so at the
time when she got married her man that
might have been the best that she could
get at the time but as she elevates
herself past him then she's in a new tax
bracket with new men who are at a higher
level therefore that her pergamos nature
starts to kick in again and says i can
do better than what i currently have
neglecting that the man
in this situation is also contributing
to the dynamic of that relationship
there's contributing and is acting on it
so yes a man wouldn't divorce a woman
necessarily because she always wanted
him whereas
because she owns one but it may be hell
in that and this is the part that nobody
is going into so should she stay in a
house where it's hellish but this is the
thing
he tends to be more passive so what are
the chances that he would actually be
raising hell in the house and you also
have to think about this logically as
well what if we're talking about such a
higher percentage figure of 70 percent
of women leave but the more high
educated more money they make you can't
then argue like logically that most of
those situations have got the man's
given her health she's doing better for
herself
why is there not surveys on actually the
reasons why the dominant reason for one
is financial and the second is
infidelity yeah so women leave for
financial reasons
women and men and women and men cheat at
similar rates it's like 23 26 financial
reasons that are cited could that not
literally be that we had disharmony in
our house because i was earning more
but this is the thing though because you
know or what type financial reasons are
you talking about that
the finances aren't enough so she has to
leave and find better because a
question was you said men are held
accountable and they put that on
themselves but what i'm saying is i
think the data indicates that men are
held accountable for this because if
your woman out earns you she's out the
door
so they they men have to deal with a
consequence
where where women where if a woman if a
woman gains a bunch of weight in a
marriage which to me is like similar to
the equivalent like usually the men
don't leave i don't know what they're
saying
what you'll be saying if a woman puts on
weight it's the same as if she earns
more no i'm saying like i think that the
equivalent of a woman a woman gaining
100 pounds is like a man losing a job
and refusing to work mm-hmm i would say
it's something like information full of
attractions instead of what what we are
what we're attracted to
okay because we women are attracted to
money money and status whereas
we're visual creatures yeah
okay so if you take the visual aspect
away from it then
that's when they start treating with
cheating with the secretary and it gets
all happening i can kind of uh see where
that's going i i half kind of agree yeah
so what i'm saying is is women don't
seem to fit like i don't know a lot of
men in real time that are leaving their
woman because she gained weight